طبعا اللجنه الدوليه اللي هي الصليب
الاحمر يعني الاليه العمل هنا في خصوصا
نتحدث عن
مطار قام
ت الفضي جلب الاشخاص
المحتجزين الذين تم الافراج عنهم الى
المطار في الصباح الباكر
في
مقابله من انهم قادرون صحيا وجسمانيا على
الصعود على الطائره والسفر الى الصنعه
المطار عدن الدولي الى صنعاء وايضا هبطت
طائره اخرى في مطار عدن دوري قبل دقائق
قليله سيتم خلال هذا اليوم التبادل
او الاهميه 249 محتجزه السابق بين اطراف
الاذاعه المسلح ونحن لا نتحدث
ماذا عن الحاله الصحيه لهؤلاء الاسر الذين
تم الاعلان عن تبادل او تبادله
هل الجميع في حاله صحيه جيده
الاشخاص الذين تم الافراج عنهم هنالك بعض
الحالات التي تحتاج مساعده طبيه لكنها
حالات قليله ومعدوده وام اللجنه والهلال
الاحمر اليمني يقولوا يقومون بمساعدتهم
واستيحابهم الى الطائره لكن
الاشخاص المحتجزين
كانوا سعداء للغايه وكانوا
يتبادل يعني يحصلون بعض واجواء شاعريه جدا
في في المطار هنا ويبدونا في صحه جيده الى
حد ما بدا يتبع عمليه وصولهم مثلا الى
صنعاء او الى عدن بعد ذلك
عفوا ممكن اعاده السؤال كنت اسال عن دور
اللجنه الدوليه بعد وصولها الاسرى الى
مطار عدن او الى صنعاء
كيف يتم التعامل معهم
بدفع مصاريف شخصيه مبالغ بسيطه وايضا
الاشخاص السفر الى مناطقهم الاصليه عفوا
انا في المطار فهتسمع اصوات فتقوم احمد
بدافع مبالغ معينه للاشخاص يستطيعون السفر
الى الى مناطقهم ايضا تقوم اللجنه الدوليه
لاصلي بالاحمر او تتيح اللجنه الدوليه
لهؤلاء الاشخاص للتواصل مع المنظمه في وقت
لاحق اذا ما ارادوا ذلك لمتابعه المزيد من
الاخبار والبرامج والقصص الانسانيه
والوثائقيات والتقارير الاخباريه لا تنسوا
الاشتراك في قناتنا على يوتيوب الضغط على
زر الاعجاب وتفعيل جرس التنبيهات